ليلى وفي عاصمه النور باريس تستعرض
السعوديه ملف استضافتها المنتظره في حفل
الاستقبال الرسمي لمعرض الرياض اكسبو 2030
بحضور الامير محمد بن سلمان الذي يقوم
بزياره رسميه لفرنسا ثلاث مدن عالميه
تنافس العاصمه السعوديه في سباقها نحو
اكسبو هي مدينه بوسان الكوريه الجنوبيه
ومدينه روما الايطاليه واخيرا مدينه
اوديسا في اوكرانيا والاخيره تعتبر اقل
حظا لعدم اجتيازها المتطلبات الفنيه
للمكتب الدولي للمعارض على ماذا تراهن
الرياض ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان اكد التزام الرياض بتقديم تجربه
عالميه غير مسبوقه وهذا اعلان السعوديه
ووعدها لترشيح استضافه الرياض لمعرض اكسبو
الدولي اكتوبر 2030 هو موعد انطلاق المعرض
الدولي اكسبو ويستمر حتى ابريل من العام
دعونا نتعرف اكثر على ملف الرياض لاستضافه
الحدث العالمي اختار الفريق المعني بالملف
موقعا مميزا لمعرض اكسبو شماليه مدينه
الرياض يمتد على مساحه سته ملايين متر
مربع ويقع ولا بعد اقل من عشر دقائق من
مطار الملك سلمان الدولي بعد جاهزيته قبل
العام 2030 ومن المتوقع تسجيل اكثر من 40
مليون زائر لموقع المعرض في حال فوز
الرياض بالاستضافه فضلا عن اكثر من مليار
زياره من خلال منصه
الفريده في نوعها
التطور التكنولوجي تاثيرات التغير المناخي
والازدهار للجميع تعبر عن مرتكزات استضافه
الرياض للحدث العالمي الذي تسعى من خلاله
الى تعزيز الحلول المستدامه والمرونه في
التحولات التي يشهدها العالم كل هذه
المعطيات وما تتبناه الرياض في معالجه
تحديات الاستدامه والعيش والتنقل والتقدم
السريع في قائمه المدن الاكثر زياره في
العالم سياحيا وثقافيا تجعلها جاهزه
لاستضافه العالم والترحيب بملايين البشر
ليشهدوا تجربه فريده قد لا تتكرر